[Music]
my name is art arturo fontes
i was an fbi dude for approximately 28
years
people laugh at me because i left sunny
san diego with beaches and everything
and
nice big house to be in a small town in
laredo they call it the armpit of texas
[Music]
it takes you all the way to dallas and
it even goes all the way up north in the
u.s
now this is an area where there was the
biggest number of trucks
crossing the whole board it was a very
important route
the golf cart's all shifting marijuana
cocaine heroin
through texas to across the united
states
the gulf cartel was on to a good thing
but it was about to get a whole lot
better
with the north american free trade
agreement
nafta will tear down trade barriers
between our three nations
it will create the world's largest trade
zone
today we have the chance to do what our
parents did before us
we have the opportunity to remake the
world
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is more important than almost any other
area in mexico and that's why it's a
battleground it's a crown jewel
for drug trafficking everybody wants
that
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
soy de losettos
[Music]
was a genius at being able to read
people and manipulate them
he was brilliant at influencing people
to do things that
they shouldn't be doing carlos
casas
in the special forces they had radio
code
with the zed letter so they would have
like
you know z2 i'm on alert they quickly
became called
the setas or the zeds after that radio
code
ocl saw in them a discipline that your
regular trafficker
did not have and that was a militarized
discipline
a respect for chain of command loyalty
the willing to attack the hill when told
regardless of the outcome
we saw that the zetas were becoming a
threat
there was definitely a foreboding of
things to come
as the zetas began to grow and become
stronger and they were learning the drug
trade
from the golf cartel
ocl is definitely in the crosshairs of
the fbi and dea he is public enemy
number one
he arrest like a scene out of
afghanistan
iraq
the mexican military i believe may have
lost one or two soldiers during the
course of that gun battle
well seattle survived he was apprehended
but it was quite the shootout
[Music]
you